[موسيقى]
مساء الخير كلمت حضراتكم قبل كده عن
كواليس المفاوضات بين امريكا والسعوديه
حول التطبيع مع اسرائيل وما يجب ان يسبق
ذلك من توقيع اتفاق امني بين المملكه
واشنطن وما يجب ان يتلوه من
تنازلات كما يصفونها من الجانب الاسرائيلي
للفلسطينيين
المفاوضات بتجري في الغرف المغلقه منذ
شهور ويتمنى بيضا انجازها قبيله انشغاله
تماما بحملته الانتخابيه لولايه ثانيه
والانتخابات الامريكيه طبعا سوف تجري في
نوفمبر 202
يوليو الماضي يعني من عده ايام
كتب الصحفي الامريكي الشهير جدا توماس
فريدمان مقالا في صحيفه نيويورك تايمز كشف
فيه عن مزيد من الكواليس عن هذه المفاوضات
الهامه ومصدر معلومات فريدمن هو الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن نفسه الذي التقاه
فريدمان في منتصف يوليو الماضي المقال مهم
جدا ليس فقط بسبب ما يحمله من معلومات
حقيقه الامر كثير من المعلومات التي جاءت
في المقال سبقه اليها صحفيون اخرون وعلى
راسهم طبعا
صحفي
اللي انفردوا بالكشف عن كواليس هذه
المفاوضات منذ عده شهور استاذنكم ارجعوا
للحلقه السابقه العنوانها شروط السعوديه
الثلاث للتطبيع مع السعوديه
حتى لا نكرر ما جاء فيها لكن اهم ما جاء
في مقال فريدمان امران بالنسبه لنا في
العالم العربي ومنطقه الشرق الاوسط الاول
انه بيكشف عن رؤيه بيضا وح لهذه الصفقه
المعقده المحتمله اي ماذا يريد بايدن او
الامريكان فضلا عمت ماذا تريد السعوديه
والصعوبات التي قد تفشل هذه الصفقه الامر
الثاني ان المقال بيوضح تصورا واضحا
للمقابل الذي قد تدفعه اسرائيل للفوز
بالتطبيع مع السعوديه افتح قوسين واضح ان
المقال له اهداف داخليه اخرى منها حشد
الدعم لصفقه بايدن الذي عليه ان يخوض
معارك في الكونجرس لتمرير هذه الصفقه ولكن
هذه قصه اخرى فريدمان كان حريصا ان يؤكد
في مقاله انه بيض ما زال في مرحله استكشاف
لمواقف الاطراف المختلفه ومحاوله تدليل
الخلافات قبل ان يشرع في التفاوض بشكل
اكثر جديه وربما علني لانجاز هذا الاتفاق
التاريخي مره تانيه ما هو الاتفاق ولماذا
هو تاريخي الاتفاق باختصار شديد هي عمليه
مقايده ثلاثيه تطبيع سعودي مع اسرائيل
يسبقه اتفاق امني بين الولايات المتحده
والسعوديه ويتلوه تنازلات اسرائيليه
فحواها الابقاء على امكانيه قيام دوله
فلسطينيه الى جانب دوله اسرائيل مزيد من
التفاصيل المقال بيذكرنا بدايه بالمطالب
السعوديه ثلاث للتطبيع مع اسرائيل ما هي
المطالب الثلاث المطلب الاول ان تمنحها
امريكا اتفاقا امنيا او اتفاق دفاع مشترك
من شانه ان يلزم الولايات المتحده
بالدفاع عن السعوديه اذا تعرضت الى اي
هجوم على ان يكون هذا الاتفاق رسمي اي
يقره الكونجرس ولا يستطيع ان يتنصل منه اي
رئيس امريكي قادم وبالتالي تتمتع السعوديه
بمظله حمايه امريكيه تشبه مظله حلف شمال
الاطلسي الذي يلزم امريكا بالدفاع عن دول
الحلف وفقا للماده الخامسه من ميثاق
النيتو
المطلب الثاني ان تساعد امريكا السعوديه
في بناء برنامج نووي سلبي متطور مع احتفاظ
المملكه بالحق في تخصيب اليورانيوم الخاص
بها على اراضيها اذا اردتم المزيد من
التفاصيل ارجعوا للحلقه السابقه حتى لا
نكرر ما قلناه عن هذا البند المهم جدا
ثلاثه ان تفتح واشنطن مخازن اسلحتها
المتطوره والمحظوره الان على الرياض
لتاخذ من هذه الاسلحه ما تراه الرياض
كافيا لضمان امنيها ومن بين هذه الاسلحه
منظومه مثلا ساد للدفاع الجوي اللي بيعتقد
الخبراء العسكريين انها فعاله في التصدي
لاي هجمات صاروخيه محتمله من ايران طبعا
المقال بيكشف ايضا عن مطالب امريكا من
السعوديه للموافقه على هذه الشروط
السعوديه
وبيذكر فريدمان ثلاث مطالب رئيسيه خلافه
تضيع ما هو اول مطلب امريكي في الموافقه
على كل هذه الشروط السعوديه هو ان توافق
السعوديه على التطبيع مع اسرائيل بخلاف
هذا الشرط البديهي في كمان ثلاث شروط
بيذكرها
3 شروط رئيسيه بيذكرها في مقاله الشرط
الاول ان تنهي السعوديه الحرب في اليمن
افتح قوسين في الف علامه استفهام عما
يتوقعه الامريكان من السعوديه لان
السعوديه عاوزه تنهي الحرب بس كيف تنهيها
هذه المشكله التي تواجه السعوديه الان
اثنين حزمه مساعدات السعوديه كبيره وغير
مسبوقه للمؤسسات الفلسطينيه في الضفه
الغربيه ثلاثه وهو الاهم واشنطن الحد من
العلاقات المتناميه بين السعوديه والصين
امريكا على سبيل المثال قلقه جدا من
احتمال قبول السعوديه بيع نفقها باليوان
الصيني بدلا من الدولار كما تسرب فيه
تقارير العام الماضي لانه بسبب نفوذ
الاقتصاد او قوه الاقتصاد الصيني
ومكانه السعوديه باعتبارها اكبر مصدر
للنفط في العالم سيكون لهذا الاتفاق تاثير
سلبي جدا على قوه الدولار الامريكي
وبالتالي على مكانه واقتصاد الولايات
المتحده عالميا امريكا ايضا تريد من
السعوديه تقليص تعاملاتها مع الشركات
الصينيه العملاقه خاصه في مجال
التكنولوجيات الحساسه وعلى راس هذه
الشركات شركات هواوي
انا اتكلمت عن المطالب الرئيسيه اللي اشار
اليها فريدمان لكن هناك مطالب اخرى باتت
معروفه
يعني وبديهي الامريكان بيطلبوها كثيرا من
السعوديين من هذه المطالب على سبيل المثال
تقليل التعاون السعودي مع روسيا من خلال
منظمه اوبك بلس
وسعي السعوديه لخفض اسعار البترول خصوصا
قبل جوله الانتخابات المقبله في الولايات
المتحده علشان يعزز من فرص بايدن في الفوز
في الانتخابات وقطع الطرق على اي تحسن
محتمل بين المملكه وايران ايران يجب ان
تظل تحت ضغط كبير تشترك فيه السعوديه مع
اسرائيل ودول اخرى بقياده الولايات
المتحده طبعا انا قلت ما هو الاتفاق هذه
هي ملامح الاتفاق السؤال الثاني لماذا هذا
الاتفاق التاريخي من وجهه نظر الامريكان
على الاقل لانه بهذا الشكل سوف يحقق في
الثلاث الرئيسه امريكا والسعوديه واسرائيل
فوائد استراتيجيه هائله في قيمتها الحد
الادنى الذي سوف تحققه السعوديه هو ان
تضمن امنها باتفاق الدفاع رسمي او اتفاق
امني رسمي مع الدوله الاعظم في العالم
وستكون السعوديه بذلك ثاني دوله غير
ديمقراطيه تحظى بهذه الميزه على الاطلاق
لم يسبق للولايات المتحده ان وقعت اتفاق
دفاع مشترك مع دوله غير ديمقراطيه الا في
حاله واحده هي كوريا الجنوبيه
1953 وقتها كانت كوريا الجنوبيه غير
ديمقراطيه قبل ان تصبح دوله ديمقراطيه
فيما بعد السعوديه سوف تكون ثاني دوله
توقع على هذا الاتفاق ان تم مع الولايات
المتحده منذ يعني نشاتها وامريكا كحد ادنى
سوف تقلص من نفوذ الصين وروسيا في الشرق
الاوسط وتطوق ايران وتعيد السيطره على
الشرق الاوسط بعد اتفاق تطبيع بين اهم
حرفين لها في المنطقه اسرائيل والسعوديه
فضلا طبعا ان هذا الاتفاق سوف يعزز يقينا
زي ما قلت لحضراتكم من حدود بايدن في
الفوز في الانتخابات المقبله اما اسرائيل
فسوف تكون اكبر الرابحين فالحد الادنى هو
التطبيع مع اقوى اقتصاد عربي واسلامي
اللي هو السعوديه لكن بسبب مكانه السعوديه
الدينيه قد يفتح التطبيع معها الطريق
للسلام بين اسرائيل والعالم الاسلامي كله
بما فيه دول كبيره جدا مثل اندونيسيا
وباكستان هذه الدول لم تطبع حتى الان لكن
ربما تفكر في التطبيع اسوه بما فعلته
السعوديه ان تم هذا الاتفاق هذا ما يتخيله
الامريكان وما يتخيله الاسرائيليون تلك
امانيهم هل يتحقق ام لا هذه قصه اخرى فضلا
طبعا ان الاتفاق سوف يعزز من شعبيه
نتنياهو المتراجعه جدا هذه الايام
لكل هذه الاسباب فريدمان بيعتبر ان
الاتفاق المحتمل انت سوف يكون في اثره
اكثر اهميه من الاتفاق الذي تم بين مصر
واسرائيل في عام 1979 من وجهه نظر فريدمان
هذا الاتفاق سوف يغير خريطه الشرق الاوسط
تماما
والراجل ذهب بخياله المحلق الى ابعد من
ذلك واعتقد ان هذا الاتفاق من شانه ان
يقلل بشكل كبير من الكراهيه بين المسلمين
واليهود وهي الكراهيه اللي بيعتقد انها
ولدت منذ اكثر من قرن مع بدايه الصراع
اليهودي الفلسطيني
كل ما سبق مهم
وكاشف عن مضمون ما يجري وراء الكواليس بين
الدول الثلاث السعوديه وامريكا مفاوضات
مباشره والاسرائيليون طبعا يتابعون هذه
المفاوضات بشكل غير مباشر من خلال اصدقائي
من امريكا لكن معظمه كمعلومات ليس جديدا
تماما تحس ان انت سمعته قبل كده الجديد في
تقديري هو ان اسرائيل وفقا لما كشافه في
رتبا في حقيقه الامر سوف تستفيد من هذا
التطبيع دون ان تدفع اي مقابل يذكر اذ ان
الثمن الذي سوف تدفعه اسرائيل للحصول على
التطبيع مع السعوديه هو الابقاء فقط على
امكانيه حل الدوله
وكيف تبقي على هذه الامكانيه بالتعهد
رسميا بالتخلي عن ضم الضفه الغربيه
والتوقف عن زياده المستوطنات فيها اي فقط
بكف اذاه عن الفلسطينيين والتوقف عن
ابتلاع مزيدا من اراضيهم كان ولا يزال
الموقف السعودي المعلم انه لا تطبيع مع
اسرائيل بدون قيام دوله فلسطينيه واحيانا
بيستخدموا تعبير اخر دون حل للصراع بين
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين والمفروض الحل
يكون هو هو قيام الدوله المفروض يكون
التعبيرين يؤدوا لنفس النتيجه اخر هذه
التصريحات جاء على سبيل المثال من السفاره
السعوديه في واشنطن في يونيو الماضي اللي
هي بتربط اي تطبيع محتمل مع اسرائيل
بحل للصراع الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني هذا
الشرط بدا للامريكان وبدا للاسرائيليين
شرطا تعجيزيا فقيام دوله ان قامت يحتاجوا
طبعا اذا صدقت النوايا وهي غير صادقه
لسنوات طويله لكن الواضح ان الامريكان
بيسعوا الان من خلال المفاوضات اللي بتجري
مع السعوديه لبلوره هذا المطلب ليكون في
حقيقه الامر بدلا من دوله فلسطينيه ليكون
الحفاظ على امكانيه قيم دوله فلسطينيه ثم
تقوم الدوله ان قامت حين تسمح الظروف وكيف
يتم الحفاظ على هذا الامل او هذه
الامكانيه بالامتناع عن ضم الضفه ووقف
مزيد من الاستيطان اليهودي داخلها بحيث
نظريا يمكن للفلسطينيين التفاوض مع
اسرائيل على قيام دوله ما على هذه الاراضي
مضافا اليها غزه في المستقبل خمس ملاحظات
الملحوظه الاولى وللدقه فريدمان اقترح على
السعوديين والامريكان ان يطلبوا من
نتنياهو اربعه مطالب مقابل هذه الجائزه
الضخمه التي سوف تهدى اليه في شكل تطبيع
مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه المطلب الاول
وعد رسمي بعدم ضم الضفه على الاطلاق الى
الابد اثنين لا مستوطنات جديد لا مستوطنات
جديده في الضفه الغربيه ابدا او التوسع
خارج المستوطنات القائمه بالفعل ثلاثه لا
تقنين للبؤر الاستيطانيه اليهوديه خارج
هذه المستوطنات
اربعه نقل بعض الاراضي الماهوله
بالفلسطينيين من المنطقه ج فالضفه الغربيه
الخاضعه الان للسلطه الاسرائيليه الى
المناطق الف وباء الخاضعه للسلطه
الفلسطينيه
على النحو المنصوص عليه في اتفاقات اسلو
وفي المقابل يتعين على السلطه الفلسطينيه
مباركه اتفاق السلام والتطبيع بين
السعوديه واسرائيل طبعا ده تصور خاص
بفريدمن وهو طبعا
بيقرب بالواقع اللي ممكن يفكر فيه
الاسرائيليين والامريكان انه يمكن ان نفكر
في وعد الفلسطينيين بعدم ضم مزيد من الضفه
وده معناه برضو انه الفلسطينيين سوف
يسلموا انه المستوطنات اصبحت جزء من
الدوله الاسرائيليه ولا يجوز لهم ان
يطالبوه بها ومقترح فريدمان اجمالا عباره
عن تفاصيل لمقترح كبير وهو تنازل اسرائيل
عن قدم مزيد من اراضي الفلسطينيه الملحوظه
الثانيه ان عمليه الضم اللي هي الضم الضفه
الغربيه من جانب اسرائيل
بتلقى معارضه ليس من دول العالم الاخرى
فقط
ولكن من معظم قاده اسرائيل بما فيهم
نتنياهو نفسه هو هدد او وعد يعني
داخله اكثر من مره بالضم لكنه لم يفعلها
ابدا من بكاء الى السلطه لاول مره في 2009
ليس بسبب احترامه للقانون
ولا حبا منه في السلام ولكن بسبب الصعوبات
الهائله اللي هتنجم عن عمليه الضم وابسطها
ماذا يفعل باراضي تضم حوالي اثنين وتسعه
من عشره مليون فلسطيني كيف يتعامل مع
الغضب الدولي الهائل اللي ناتج عن قرار
رفضهم لقرار سوف يفجر المنطقه وهي هادئه
نسبيا ماذا يفعل مع رد فعل الدول المهمه
في المنطقه وعلى راسها الاردن اللي هكون
في غاضبه جدا لان هذا القرار يعني مساله
حياه او موت للدوله الاردنيه ويهدد امنها
القومي بشكل رئيسي من يسعى حقيقه للضم هم
المتطرفون من قاده المستوطنات او متطرفون
دينيا اللي تحالف معهم نتنياهو في حكومته
الحاليه فقط لا غير ليه هؤلاء المتطرفين
اكثر اهتماما بالضفه من
التطبيع مع السعوديه مع باقي دول العالم
الاسلامي مجموعه طويله من الاسباب منها
اولا اجندته بالداخليه باعتبارهم قاده
مستوطنات وراغبين في تكريس احتلالهم
للاراضي التي يسيطرون عليها الان في الضفه
الغربيه منها قناعتهم الدينيه
والاهم من كل ذلك قناعه الكثير من اليهود
انه يمكنهم الجمع بين تم الضفه الغربيه
والاستيلاء عليها وبين الحصول على فوائد
التعاون مع الدول العربيه ودول الاسلاميه
كثيره اما سرا كما فعلوا على مدار عشرات
السنوات السابقه او حتى يقنعوا دولا
بالتطبيع معهم رغم مخططهم لضم الضفه كما
فعلوا مع الامارات ومع البحرين الى اخره
الملحوظه الثالثه
لاحظ انه التعهد بعدم ضم الضفه كان
التزاما تعهدت به اسرائيل قبل ذلك مقابل
التطبيع مع الامارات والبحرين في 2020
تضمن اتفاق التطبيع على الاقل مع الامارات
في ديسمبر 2020 في اغسطس 2020
تعهد من بنيامين نتنياهو على تاجيل الضم
حتى عام 2024 وفقا للمعلومات اللي كانت
منشوره الان بنفس التعهد تريد اسرائيل ان
تطبع مع السعوديه يعني تدفع تحصل على
شيئين بنفس الثمن لكن التسريبات بتقول ان
السعوديين يريدون تعهدا بعدم الضم الى
الابد هل هذا ممكن
بيقول اه ممكن حتى في ظل الحكومه الحاليه
المتطرفه والمتشدده جدا اذ ان المنطق من
وجهه نظر فريدمان ان تطبيع العلاقات مع
السعوديه
والتطبيع المحتمل مع بقيه دول العالم
الاسلامي سوف يكون اكثر اهميه من مخاطره
ضم الضفه التي يسكنها نحو ثلاثه ملايين
فلسطيني حتى بالنسبه لهؤلاء المتطرفين
الذين يحكمون اسرائيل الان لكن في الايام
التاليه لنشر مقال فريدمان رد عليه
اسرائيليون ليقولوا له انت فاهم غلط يا
سيد
بالنسبه لهؤلاء المتطرفين ضم الضفه اهم
بكثير من التطبيع مع السعوديه وليس لدى
معظم هؤلاء على الاقل اي نيه للتخلي عن
خطه الضم ويبدو ان الامريكان بيستعدوا
لهذا الاحتمال باقناع المعارضه
الاسرائيليه في حال انسحبت هذه العناصر
المتطرفه من الائتلاف الحاكم وسقطت حكومه
نتنياهو بيحاول الامريكان اقناع المعارضه
بان هم يتجاوز الخلافتهم معا نتنياهو
ويشكلوا معه حكومه بدون هؤلاء المتطرفين
حكومه تقبل بهذه الصفقه التي تحمل تغيرات
التاريخيه لدوله اسرائيل لننتظر ونرى
الملحوظه الرابعه ان امريكا بتطلب من
السعوديه وليس اسرائيل حزمه ماليه غير
مسبوقه من المساعدات لتحسين اوضاع
الفلسطينيين اللي تدهورت اوضاعهم من جراء
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي امر غريب جدا ان
اسرائيل لا تتكبد ولا يطلب منها ان تشارك
حتى في رفع المعاناه اللي الحقها احتلالها
بالضفه
الحقها احتلالها للضفه بالفلسطينيين يعني
في الحرب الدائره الان بين روسيا
واوكرانيا امريكا بتقود حمله غربيه لايجاد
وسائل لارغام روسيا على دفع تكاليف ما
دمرته اله الحرب الروسيه بالاوكران اما في
حاله اسرائيل
في الولايات المتحده بتطلب من دوله اخرى
ان تتحمل
تكاليف ما خربه الاسرائيليون في الضفه
الملحوظه الخامسه والاخطر ان كل التسريبات
الامريكيه والاسرائيليه
مبنيه على انه
السعوديه مثل باقي الدول العربيه غير
معنيه بفلسطين والفلسطينيين وان السعوديه
مثل الدول العربيه الاخرى سوف تقنع باي
حلول شكليه للقضيه الفلسطينيه التي لا
يهتمون بها في حقيقه الامر وان معنى كده
ان التطبيع مع السعوديه قادم قادم اذا
لبيت مطالب السعوديين بغض النظر عن المسار
الفلسطيني وان المساله سوف يعني تنتهي
بحمله علاقات عامه لا يحصل الفلسطينيون
بموجبها على اي حقوق فعليه
وانه نتنياهو عنده قناعه كبيره بان هذا ما
سوف يجري مع السعوديه كما جرى مع الدول
العربيه الاخرى خصوصا في الاتفاقات
الابراهيميه وان كل الدول العربيه
والاسلاميه سوف تطبع من باب السلام مقابل
السلام والتعاون مع اسرائيل وامريكا وليس
من باب السلام مقابل تنازل الاسرائيليين
عن اراضي للفلسطينيين من اين جاءوا بهذه
القناعه ما مدى دقتها اسئله سوف نحتاج
وقتا للاجابه عليها
الاجابه سوف تكون واضحه حين تسفر
المفاوضات السريه الحاليه عن نتائج علنيه
وحين يتحدث السعوديون في الوقت الحالي من
يتحدث هم الامريكان والاسرائيليون اما
السعوديون
فيفضلون التفاوض سرا ويقرون حساباتهم في
الغرف المغلقه ويلتزمون الصمت امام
الكاميرات وبالتالي علينا ان ننتظر ونرى
ويكون لنا مع تطورات هذا الشان حلقات اخرى
باذن الله اشكركم والى اللقاء